hey hey Mark Zuckerberg was once on his
way to becoming the richest person in
the world in September of 2021 his net
worth reached 142 billion making him the
third richest person on Earth this man
gave birth to the social media industry
yet today the Facebook founder has seen
his net worth slashed by more than a
hundred billion moving him down to 28th
Place on the Bloomberg billionaires
index the Zuckerberg's fall reflects
that of his company at one point Meadow
was valued at one trillion today
Facebook's parent company has lost three
quarters of its value its market value
is now lower than that of Home Depot
on November 9 meta announced it was
laying off 11 000 people or 13 of its
Workforce that's nearly triple the
number of employees Elon Musk let go
from Twitter the week before
in a message posted to his company's
website Zuckerberg wrote I know this is
tough for everyone and I'm especially
sorry to those impacted
meta has burned billions spending so
furiously on its virtual world that
predictions are it could eventually cost
more than the entire Apollo Moon program
which was more than 250 billion adjusted
for inflation we believe the metaverse
will be the successor to the mobile
internet we believe in this Vision so
deeply that we renamed our whole company
after it in October 2021 Facebook the
company officially changed its name to
meta to reflect a new Focus the
metaverse is a vision of the future
where people share Virtual Worlds
through virtual reality or augmented
reality headsets Quest Pro is the first
in our new line of advanced headsets in
the same way that everyone has a
smartphone today Zuckerberg is betting
they'll have a headset tomorrow
he's been intentionally pivoting away
from Facebook Facebook's own research
shows it's struggling to keep young
people interested its number of daily
active users dropped at the end of 2021
for the first time and Tick Tock has
been taking away eyeballs from meta's
Instagram while WhatsApp doesn't run ads
it was already a painful year for meta
before announcing the large-scale
layoffs in November meta dropped 232
billion in value in one day in February
Zuckerberg blamed it partly on Apple's
privacy changes which gave iPhone users
the choice of whether they'd allow apps
like Facebook to monitor their online
activity if people opt out Facebook
receives less user data which makes
targeting ads more difficult costing the
company ad Revenue
but what's really been dragging down
meta's profit is the ridiculous spending
on the metaverse hey
spending on the metaverse is absolutely
Bonkers meta spent 10 billion on the
metaverse in 2021 alone that's 10 times
what it paid to buy Instagram 10 years
ago 10 billion dollars was just a number
that I had trouble processing it just I
feel sick to my stomach thinking about
that much money being spent John Carmack
is an advisor to meta and the former
Chief technology officer at Oculus the
VR company Facebook acquired his
comments put him at odds with Zuckerberg
who has put all his eggs in one
metaverse basket
Zuckerberg is committed to a division of
meta called reality Labs which makes VR
and AR headsets and software reality
Labs reportedly has 17
000 employees that's four times the size
of Twitter's entire Workforce like other
tech companies meta went on a hiring
spree during the pandemic as everyone
was locked away at home on their
computer but now Zuckerberg admits meta
grew too quickly the global economy has
slowed inflation has soared and
investors are nervous about costs
Facebook has weathered storms before
even scandals related to privacy and
misinformation didn't hurt its financial
performance but this time it's different
although tech stocks have been in a
slump meta's problems far outpace both
the NASDAQ and the S P 500 November's
job cuts are the most significant since
the company was founded in 2004 a hiring
freeze will be extended until March 2023
employees will lose some perks they
already lost free Laundry and Dry
Cleaning earlier in the year
Zuckerberg is asking his employees and
investors to trust him and his plan for
the metaverse in fact he's made himself
the face of his company's push for the
metaverse according to the New York
Times some meta employees refer to
metaverse projects as mmh an acronym for
make Mark happy
but he wasn't very happy after he posted
a selfie in Meadow's virtual reality
Network Horizon worlds and the world
laughed at him for how ridiculous it
looked people on Twitter were ruthless
comparing Horizon worlds to something
outdated from decades ago in response to
the mocking Zuckerberg promised the
graphics would get a lot better and
shared an improved version three days
later but even meta's employees are
barely using its own metaverse app in
September the Vice President in charge
of meta's metaverse division Michelle
Shah wrote in an internal Message Board
obtained by The Verge the simple truth
is if we don't love it how can we expect
our users to love it
he said managers would start tracking
employees use of horizon worlds
nearly all of Zuckerberg's wealth is
tied up in metastalk so he's betting his
entire fortune on the success of his
vision for the future
during meta's earnings call in October
Zuckerberg defiantly said I get that a
lot of people might disagree with this
investment I think people are going to
look back on decades from now and talk
about the importance of the work that
was done here
but for now as one headline proclaims
its metaverse dream feels as far away as
ever
it remains to be seen whether the
metaverse will transform Our Lives
there is another company transforming
the Shaving industry Henson knows a
thing or two about making a great
product because their razors are
manufactured in the same machine shop in
Canada that built parts for the
International Space Station so their
razors are made to Aerospace standards
the blade is only minimally exposed the
amount that the blade extends past the
shave plane is less than the thickness
of a strand of human hair which allows
Henson to limit the blade from flexing
to deliver that smooth and safe shave
Henson has sponsored quite a few of my
videos and my viewers really love their
products their razors are completely
plastic free and so are their blades the
blades only cost about 10 cents so once
you own a Henson razor it's only about
three to five dollars a year to shave
depending on how often you shave their
safety razor lasts years if not decades
so over time the cost of owning a Henson
is much less than a cartridge razor plus
it's environmentally friendly Henson
ships all around the world and they're
offering you a special deal if you use
my discount code newsthink you'll get a
pack of a hundred blades for free be
sure to add the 100 pack to your
shopping cart first before entering my
code my custom link is in the
description and by the way their razors
also make for a great gift
thanks for watching for news think I'm
Cindy Palm